>> LAST TIME ON "TOP MODEL"...
>> THAT VIDEO WILL BE POSTED
ON covergirl.com.
>> AND ACTION.
>> I LOVE STARTING OUT--
WAIT. (groans)
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> YES, IT DOES.
>> YOU'RE FINE.
THIS BITCH--I CAN'T STAND HER
BECAUSE I REALLY WANNA WIN.
>> LOOKS LIKE TEAM 1
AND BRITTANI WORKED THAT OUT.
>> AAH!
>> JUST SEND THE GIRL
WITH THE BAD ATTITUDE HOME.
I DON'T CARE
HOW GOOD HER PICTURES ARE.
NO ONE IN THE INDUSTRY IS
GONNA WANNA WORK WITH HER.
>> (growls)
>> THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> I WAS, LIKE, THE MAMA JAGUAR,
AND MURATO WAS MY BABY.
>> THE SHOTS ARE AMAZING.
IT WAS JUST A STRUGGLE,
I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
>> THIS ISN'T FASHION.
I MEAN, SHE'S JUST
NOT TAKING ANY RISKS.
>> AND DALYA WAS ELIMINATED.
EIGHT GIRLS ARE LEFT,
BUT ONLY ONE WILL HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO DO YOU THINK
WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH.
>> TYRA!
>> HI!
WE WALK INTO THE HOUSE
AFTER ELIMINATION,
AND WE SAW TYRA.
IT WAS JUST A GREAT SURPRISE
'CAUSE WE HAVEN'T REALLY HAD
MUCH, LIKE, FACE-TO-FACE TIME
WITH HER
EXCEPT FOR AT PANEL.
>> THREE GIRLS
ON THE RUNWAY HERE
AND FIVE BACK THERE.
EVERYBODY GET
YOUR PAD AND PAPER.
ARE WE DOING GOOD?
>> YEAH.
>> YES? MOLLY, HOW'S THE WEAVE?
(record needle scratches)
>> WHAT--ARE YOU SAD?
>> I'M JUST KIND OF UPSET
RIGHT NOW.
>> TELL ME WHY.
>> (crying) I'M JUST--I'M--
THIS IS PISSING ME OFF.
I NEED TO EAT.
(chuckles) I'M JUST HAVING
A LITTLE MELTDOWN,
BUT IT'S NOTHING.
>> ABOUT A WEAVE AND SOME FOOD?
>> I HAVE A RASH
ON THE BACK OF MY NECK.
THIS IS REALLY TIGHT ON MY HEAD.
I'M, LIKE, HAVING A BAD DAY.
>> I THINK MOLLY
COMPLAINS TOO MUCH,
AND IT'S, LIKE,
YOU SHOULD BE SO GRATEFUL
THAT WE'RE IN THIS SITUATION,
HAVING THIS OPPORTUNITY.
>> JUST TO LET YOU KNOW,
WEAVES
DODO THAT,
LIKE, THEY CREATE RASHES,
LITTLE BUMPS,
ESPECIALLY ON THE TIGHT AREAS.
IT'S PART
OF THAT BEAUTY/PAIN THING.
BUT WE'RE GONNA SUCK IT UP,
RIGHT?
IT WILL BE REMOVED.
WE'RE IN SCHOOL.
ARE WE READY FOR OUR SESSION?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
JACLYN, HANNAH,
MONIQUE, KASIA,
MIKAELA, MOLLY,
BRITTANI, ALEXANDRIA--
AS DIFFERENT AS YOU ARE,
ALL OF YOU GUYS HAVE
AN ARCHETYPE,
A CERTAIN SECTION
OF THE MODELING INDUSTRY
THAT YOU FIT IN.
AND NO MATTER
WHAT ARCHETYPE YOU ARE,
ALL OF THOSE ARCHETYPES
CAN STILL BE HIGH FASHION.
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
WHAT TYPES THEY ARE.
WHO'S THAT?
>> GISELE.
>> GISELE-Y.
AND WHAT DO YOU SAY GISELE IS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SEXY.
>> SEX BOMB.
WHEN YOU ARE THE SEX BOMB
THAT DOES FASHION,
YOU SELL BRAS AND PANTIES
AND ALL TYPES OF THINGS
TO WOMEN EVERYWHERE.
(European accent) THIS IS COCO.
(normal voice) WHAT DO YOU THINK
SHE'S EMBODYING IN THIS PHOTO?
>> FRESH-FACED, ALL-AMERICAN.
>> FRESH, ALL-AMERICAN.
GIRL NEXT DOOR.
IT'S ABOUT BEING LIKEABLE.
WHO IS THIS?
>> AGYNESS DEYN.
>> AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
SHE EMBODIES?
>> BADASS.
>> BADASS, EDGY GIRL.
EDGY GIRLS CAN BE KINDA LIKE,
"WHAT? WHAT'D YOU SAY?
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO POSE?
WHAT?"
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST...
>> SESSILEE LOPEZ.
>> YES. KASIA KNOWS EVERYTHING.
♪♪♪♪♪
SESSILEE LOPEZ IS
A SUPER HIGH FASHION,
COUTURE-TYPE MODEL.
LET'S SMACK HER.
THERE.
SO WHO ARE YOU, LADIES?
WHAT DO WE THINK KASIA IS?
>> BOMBSHELL.
>> COUTURE AND BOMBSHELL.
>> MY BODY TYPE IS
MORE BOMBSHELL,
AND THEN THE COUTURE PART,
I THINK, YOU KNOW,
IS MY ATTITUDE AND DEMEANOR.
>> JACLYN.
WHAT DO WE THINK SHE IS?
>> GIRL NEXT DOOR.
>> I THINK SO, TOO.
SMACK IT.
MONIQUE.
>> BOMBSHELL.
>> BOMBSHELLS...
ARE ONLY JUDGED BY HOW THEY KNOW
HOW TO PICK UP SOMETHING
THAT JUST DROPPED.
>> OOH! YEAH!
>> I'M REALLY FLATTERED
BY BEING A BOMBSHELL.
LIKE, THAT'S WHAT MY--
MY WHOLE GOAL IS.
I'M LIKE, HELL, YEAH!
>> ALEXANDRIA,
GET YOUR BUTT UP HERE.
WHAT DO WE THINK ALEXANDRIA IS?
>> EDGY.
>> YOU DON'T THINK
SHE'S GOT A LITTLE...
>> HEY!
>> EDGY BOMBSHELL.
COME ON OVER HERE, BRITTANI.
WHAT IS SHE?
>> COUTURE.
>> I AGREE. AND EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE HIGH FASHION, GIRL,
SMACK IT!
LAST BUT NOT LEAST--MIKAELA.
MIKAELA!
>> COUTURE.
>> COUTURE?
YEAH, I THINK SO, TOO.
BUT SHE'S SCARED AND SAD.
SHE'S SCARED TO LET
THE BOMBSHELL OUT.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU GOTTA--
YOU GOTTA SHAKE IT OUT.
YEAH. H-HANDS IN YOUR HAIR,
AND, LIKE...
>> I THINK YOU COULD.
>> YEAH, I THINK SO, TOO.
>> MAYBE THAT'S WHY
I HAVE BEEN UNDERPERFORMING
AT MY PHOTO SHOOTS.
MAYBE I'M JUST NOT FEELING
LIKE A BOMBSHELL.
MAYBE I'M NOT FEELING
SEXY ENOUGH.
>> SO WE'VE GOT OUR ARCHETYPES.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT
YOUR FAVORITE SUPERMODELS,
THEY'RE NOT JUST KINDA LIKE,
OH, SHE'S JUST KINDA EVERYTHING.
THESE GIRLS ALL HAVE
SOMETHING VERY SPECIFIC,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
CAN RELATE TO SO MANY PEOPLE.
AND WHEN YOU BECOME
A REALLY SUCCESSFUL MODEL,
SOMETHING HAPPENS--
FAME.
(camera shutters click)
>> FAME IS GOING TO COME
FOR THIS WINNER.
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THE FAME?
>> I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT BEING FAMOUS AT ALL.
I JUST LOVE PEOPLE
AND I LOVE LITTLE KIDS,
AND I THINK IT'D BE AWESOME
TO HAVE PEOPLE
LOOK UP TO YOU LIKE THAT.
>> HOW CLOSE ARE YOU
GONNA LET YOUR PUBLIC
GET TO YOU?
I HAVE MY BOUNDARIES.
I WON'T TAKE PICTURES
WHEN I'M EATING,
BUT I MIGHT TAKE A PICTURE
IF I'M IN A PRIVATE PLACE.
IF I TAKE A PICTURE
IN A PUBLIC PLACE,
THEN A LOT OF PEOPLE COME UP.
THEN YOU GET THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS MY SISTER'S BROTHER'S
UNCLE'S COUSIN,
AND SHE LOVES YOU.
TALK TO HER! TALK TO HER!"
>> I WOULD DO, LIKE,
AUTOGRAPHS ANY TIME,
BUT I WOULD NEVER TALK
TO SOMEONE ON A CELL PHONE.
THAT'S JUST TOO MUCH.
>> NO, I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
>> WELL, I'VE DONE IT,
AND SOMETIMES IT'S, LIKE,
A TEN MINUTE CONVERSATION.
"UH-HUH. I'M ME."
"SAY SOMETHING, TYRA.
SAY SOMETHING."
"COMING UP ON
'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.'"
"OH, MY GOD! AAH!"
>> IT IS DEFINITELY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE BOUNDARIES
WITH YOUR FANS.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF, LIKE,
REALLY WEIRD PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD.
I'M, LIKE, I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
WHAT, LIKE, TYRA GOES THROUGH.
>> I'M GONNA TEACH YOU GUYS
HOW TO SIGN AUTOGRAPHS NOW.
MY SIGNATURE AUTOGRAPH IS
A HEART LIKE THAT,
AND I DO A STRAIGHT "T,"
LIKE THAT.
EVERY NOW AND THEN,
I'LL ADD A "B."
I WANT YOU TO SIGN
WHAT YOU THINK
YOUR AUTOGRAPH SHOULD BE.
AND MAKE IT SPECIAL,
'CAUSE MINE SUCKS.
THE HEART--IT'S, LIKE,
EVERYBODY DOES THAT.
>> I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
MY AUTOGRAPH SINCE I WAS,
LIKE, A LITTLE GIRL.
>> LAME!
>> THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS DO.
>> LET'S WORK ON NO HEART,
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY LAME.
SO IT'S, LIKE,
DO AS I SAY, NOT AS I DO.
>> I MEAN, IT'S CHANGED,
EVOLVED, BUT I, YEAH,
I GUESS I KNEW
I'D NEED IT ONE DAY.
>> READY TO MOVE ON?
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS WORD IS?
IT MEANS "SKIN" IN SPANISH.
PIEL.
HOW THICK IS YOUR SKIN?
YOU GUYS ARE YOUNG
AND GO ON THE INTERNET
AND STUFF.
THERE'S ALL KIND
OF CRAZY STUFF ABOUT ME.
AND DOES IT HURT?
IT STILL HURTS TO THIS DAY.
BUT I HAVE LEARNED
TO SEPARATE IT.
BUT IT WILL ALWAYS HURT
BECAUSE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT ME.
WHO WANTS TO JUST TALK
ABOUT THAT,
ABOUT HOW SENSITIVE
OR NOT SENSITIVE
THEY THINK THEY ARE?
>> I'M AS TOUGH AS A DIAMOND.
UM, THAT'S THE TOUGHEST THING
YOU CAN BE,
AND THAT'S JUST BECAUSE WHAT
I'VE BEEN THROUGH PERSONALLY.
THROUGHOUT MY... LIFE,
THERE'S BEEN
EVERY SINGLE KIND OF ABUSE
THAT YOU COULD IMAGINE--
PHYSICAL, VERBAL, MENTAL.
IT'S MADE ME STRONG.
IT'S PREPARED ME FOR THIS.
>> YOU GUYS NEED TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT, "AM I READY FOR THIS?
TO GO OUT THERE
AND TO PUT MYSELF
IN FRONT OF THE ENTIRE WORLD,
FOR THEM TO THROW ROSES AT ME
AND DARTS?"
OKAY?
I HOPE THIS WAS REALLY HELPFUL.
>> YES.
>> SO WE KNOW WHO WE ARE
AND WE KNOW HOW
WE'RE GONNA HANDLE THE WORLD.
AND I WILL SEE YOU LATER.
>> I THINK IT'S CRAZY
THAT I COULD POSSIBLY HAVE,
LIKE, A FAN BASE.
IT GIVES ME THIS EXCITEMENT.
>> WHAT A NICE SURPRISE.
>> OH, YEAH.
(horn honks)
>> HEY!
>> AAH!
>> TYRA WANTED MOLLY'S WEAVE
COMPLETELY OUT.
>> JUST TO LET YOU KNOW,
WEAVES DODO THAT,
LIKE, THEY CREATE RASHES,
LITTLE BUMPS,
ESPECIALLY ON THE TIGHT AREAS.
BUT IT WILL BE REMOVED.
>> SO THEY TOOK
THE WHOLE THING OUT.
>> HOW DOES
YOUR POOR, RAW SCALP FEEL?
>> IT FEELS FINE UP HERE.
I'M SO HAPPY
TO HAVE THAT CRAZY ANIMAL
OFF OF MY HEAD.
>> (laughs)
>> CAN WE JUST KEEP DOING THAT?
>> CAN WE JUST DO IT?
>> PLEASE. OH, MY GOD.
DO THIS AS MUCH AS YOU WANT.
>> I DON'T WANT TO LOOK AT THAT.
I'M JUST MAD THAT, LIKE,
I DIDN'T GET, LIKE,
SECOND AT LEAST.
>> BEST PICTURE OF THE WEEK
GOES TO...
HANNAH.
>> I'M JUST ANNOYED
THAT HANNAH WON AGAIN.
I WANT MY (bleep) PICTURE
IN THE HOUSE SO BAD.
I DON'T SEE EITHER OF YOU
GOING HOME,
AND I'M THINKING, LIKE--
LIKE I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHO WILL BE NEXT.
HEBRON, ILLINOIS,
IS SUPER SMALL.
WE HAVE, LIKE,
1,200 PEOPLE IN THE TOWN.
I GUESS THEY'RE KNOWN FOR
WINNING THE STATE CHAMPIONSHIP
FOR BASKETBALL IN 1952.
OBVIOUSLY, I CAN'T BE A MODEL
IN HEBRON, ILLINOIS.
I KNOW I HAVE, LIKE,
ENOUGH AMBITION AND DRIVE
TO GET THE HELL OUT OF THE TOWN.
(sighs)
>> UH-OH.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW YOU'LL HAVE
A REAL FOLLOWING."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> PAPARAZZI!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WELCOME, GIRLS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> HEY.
>> TODAY WE'RE
AT THE CENTURY CITY MALL
FOR AN AUTOGRAPH-SIGNING
CHALLENGE.
ONE OF YOU WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
SO YOU BETTER GET USED TO
PEOPLE ASKING FOR YOUR WHAT?
YOUR AUTOGRAPH.
LAST NIGHT, TYRA GAVE YOU
SOME TIPS ON HANDLING FAME.
YOU'LL BE TESTED
ON HOW WELL YOU CARRY YOURSELF.
SO I HOPE YOU WERE
REALLY LISTENING.
THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
WILL BE GETTING
THE A-LIST TREATMENT--
A PERSONALIZED DINNER
WITH YOURS TRULY--ME--
AT AN UPSCALE RESTAURANT.
AND NOW LET'S BRING OUT
THE FANS.
>> AFTER MY LESSON WITH TYRA,
I'M DEFINITELY READY
FOR THE FANS AND THE FAME.
>> HI. I'M KASIA.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> JASON. NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> JASON. ALEXANDRIA.
>> YOU ALL LOOK SUPER YOUNG.
>> I'M JACLYN.
>> I'M HANNAH.
>> HI.
>> ALL THESE PEOPLE
START COMING UP TO US.
IT'S JUST SO NEAT
TO GET TO TALK TO THEM.
I WANTED TO STAY THERE ALL DAY.
>> IT'S HILARIOUS THAT THEY'RE
SAYING THAT YOU ARE CURVY.
>> I'M THE PLUS SIZE.
FIERCELY REAL.
>> NO, GIRLFRIEND.
>> BUT FIERCELY REAL.
>> KASIA--
I THOUGHT SHE WAS SWEET
AND SHE WAS OPEN AND FRIENDLY,
AND I JUST APPRECIATED
HOW REAL SHE WAS.
>> WILL YOU GUYS, LIKE,
RECORD MY VOICE MAIL MESSAGE?
>> YEAH. IT'S ALEXANDRIA...
>> MOLLY...
>> AND BRITTANI...
>> FROM CYCLE 16.
>> LEAVE JENNIFER A MESSAGE.
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> CHRISTOPHER.
>> CHRISTOPHER,
NICE TO MEET YOU.
I LOVE YOUR STYLE.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> MONIQUE WAS OVER IT,
LIKE, REALLYOVER IT
HALFWAY THROUGH.
>> I'M SO COLD RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT'S JUST NOT OKAY.
LIKE, THAT'S PART OF THE JOB.
>> FAVORITE ICE CREAM FLAVOR.
I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE MODELS,
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE ONE.
>> OOH! WHAT A GREAT QUESTION.
FIRST ONE OF THE DAY.
>> BUTTER PECAN.
>> OKAY.
>> I LIKE TO THINK THAT
I AM A NICE PERSON
AND CAN TALK WELL
WITH NEW PEOPLE, BUT ALEXANDRIA
WAS JUST LIKE, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
IT WAS A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
SO THAT WAS KIND OF AGGRAVATING.
>> ARE YOU, LIKE, WEB--
ON WEB SITES?
>> NO.
>> YOU CAN BE. YOU SHOULD BE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I MEAN, LIKE, THERE'S--
I KNOW PEOPLE HERE IF YOU WANTED
TO DO STUFF LIKE THAT.
>> OH, THANKS.
THAT'S VERY CONSIDERATE OF YOU.
WE'RE MEETING THESE PEOPLE,
AND I JUST WANTED TO BE LIKE,
"CAN YOU GO NOW?
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO TALK
TO YOU ANYMORE."
>> IT WAS AWESOME MEETING YOU.
>> UM, THANK YOU.
>> WELL, I CAN GET A--
CAN YOU SIGN THAT?
>> SURE.
>> DO YOU WANT--
YOU CAN WRITE
"I'M A GOOD KISSER" ON IT.
>> MAYBE ALEXANDRIA
WILL DO THAT FOR YOU.
>> WAIT. WHO'S THAT?
>> MONIQUE TOLD JAMES
THAT, UM, SHE WOULDN'T KISS HIM
BUT THAT ALEXANDRIA WOULD.
AND CLEARLY, MONIQUE DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO HANDLE IT.
>> YOU SAID YOU'RE ALEXANDRIA,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> MONIQUE SAID
THAT YOU WOULD KISS ME.
>> WHAT?
>> SHE SAID SHE COULDN'T DO IT,
BUT SHE SAID THAT YOU WOULD--
THAT YOU WOULD KISS ME.
>> MY BOYFRIEND--HE'S, UM,
HE'S ABOUT MY HEIGHT.
>> THAT'S COOL.
>> HE'S AN ULTIMATE FIGHTER.
>> OKAY.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT HE WOULD,
UH...
>> IT'S NOT LIKE, WE, LIKE,
HAD SEX OR ANYTHING.
>> I KNOW, BUT... (laughs)
MOMO TOLD SOMEBODY
THAT I WOULD KISS THEM,
BECAUSE IT WAS KINDA, LIKE,
HER WAY OF GETTING OUT OF IT.
>> WE HIT IT OFF.
>> YEAH, WE HIT IT OFF,
BUT I LOVE MY BOYFRIEND.
>> YEAH, BUT WE JUST HANG OUT,
YOU KNOW, LIKE...
>> YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT
SHE WAS A SWEETHEART,
BUT IF THAT'S HOW IT'S GONNA BE,
AND, LIKE, REALLY CATTY
AND STUFF, BETTER WATCH OUT
BECAUSE I'M ONE
NOT TO BE (bleep) WITH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> YEAH.
>> I WAS STANDING IN A GROUP
WITH MOLLY AND BRITTANI,
AND, YOU KNOW,
I FEEL REALLY CONFIDENT.
>> HOW'S YOUR DAY GOING, JAMES?
>> YOU SAID
YOU'RE ALEXANDRIA, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> MONIQUE SAID THAT
YOU WOULD KISS ME.
>> WHAT?
>> SHE SAID SHE COULDN'T DO IT,
BUT SHE SAID THAT YOU WOULD--
THAT YOU WOULD KISS ME.
>> THERE WAS THIS ONE GUY,
AND MONIQUE, UH,
SENT HIM OVER TO OUR TABLE.
AND SHE TOTALLY DID IT
IN A WAY WHERE SHE WAS JUST
TRYING TO GET HIM AWAY FROM HER,
BUT DON'T SEND HIM MY WAY.
I'D DEFINITELY GIVE YOU
A KISS ON THE CHEEK.
>> OKAY.
>> IS THAT OKAY?
>> YEAH, OKAY.
>> BUT I'M SCARED.
YOU BETTER NOT...
>> TURN AND GO LIKE THAT.
>> I DIDN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT IT
UNTIL YOU JUST SAID IT.
>> 'CAUSE MY BOYFRIEND N--
TAUGHT ME HOW TO HIT. SO...
>> SHE WILL.
YOU BETTER WATCH IT.
>> (giggles) WOULD YOU LIKE
A SIGNED AUTOGRAPH?
>> YES, PLEASE.
>> OKAY.
>> DO YOU WANT TO JUST WRITE
YOUR NUMBER DOWN, AND WE CAN--
>> UM, YOU'RE FUNNY, JAMES.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> YOU, TOO.
>> IT WAS NICE MEETING YOU.
>> IT WAS NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
>> WOW.
PEOPLE ARE SO INTERESTED.
>> HOPE YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY.
>> BYE.
>> THANKS. YOU, TOO.
>> ♪ WHAT THE--HEY! ♪
>> OKAY, GIRLS.
HOW'D YOU FEEL ABOUT IT?
>> IT WAS AWESOME.
>> FUN.
>> I'M GONNA START
WITH ALEXANDRIA.
YOU WERE REALLY SWEET,
BUT YOU SHOULD'VE NEVER
KISSED THE CHEEK,
BECAUSE DOING THAT COULD
LEAD HIM ON TO STALKING YOU.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
SOMEONE ELSE TELLS THAT PERSON
THAT I WOULD DO THAT?
>> SHE CALLED YOU OUT,
AND YOU DID WHAT SHE SAID
YOU WOULD DO, SO...
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE ENDED UP GIVING HIM
A KISS ON THE CHEEK.
I MEAN, SHE DID
WHAT MONIQUE SAID SHE WOULD DO,
SO... (clicks tongue)
MONIQUE WAS RIGHT.
>> JACLYN,
YOU WERE THE GIRL NEXT DOOR
WITH A LOT
OF SQUEAKY PERSONALITY.
KASIA, YOU TALKED A LOT
WITH YOUR FANS
WHILE KEEPING IT MODEL-Y,
IF IT MAKES SENSE.
MONIQUE,
YOU STOOD THERE HALF THE TIME
LIKE...
(crickets chirping)
>> (laughs)
>> JUST SO BORED TO DEATH.
WITH EVERYTHING
THAT I JUST SAID,
THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
IS...
KASIA.
>> OH!
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU GET TO PICK TWO FRIENDS.
>> JACLYN AND BRITTANI.
>> AND YOU GIRLS WILL GO
TO A PERSONALIZED DINNER
WITH YOURS TRULY.
>> YAY!
I THINK THIS WAS A HUGE WIN.
JUST TO SIT DOWN
IN SUCH A SMALL, INTIMATE DINNER
WITH, YOU KNOW,
SOMEBODY SO INFLUENTIAL
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
IT WAS LIKE AN HONOR.
>> AND FOR THE GIRLS
WHO DIDN'T MAKE IT,
WHICH IS BASICALLY THE LOSERS,
YOU GIRLS GET TO CLEAN UP
THE FAN MESS.
AND SHE IS NOT HAPPY.
>> I SAW KASIA THE WHOLE TIME.
WE WERE BOTH
IN THE CONVERSATIONS.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW SHE EVEN--
WHY SHE WON.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> KISS MY (bleep).
THIS IS A (bleep) JOKE, OKAY?
>> I DON'T CARE.
>> LET'S JUST DO IT.
>> THIS WILL BE OVER SOON
IF WE HUSTLE.
>> MONIQUE--SHE WAS JUST
SCUFFING HER HEELS....
>> (bleep)
>> JUST HAD THE WORST ATTITUDE
ABOUT IT.
>> I'M SICK OF MY LIFE.
>> LIFE IS SO HARD RIGHT NOW,
MONIQUE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
KISS MY (bleep).
I HOPE THAT THEY HAVE
A REALLY (bleep) TIME AT DINNER,
AND I HOPE THAT
THEY GET GOOD POISONING.
AND I'M BEING SERIOUS RIGHT NOW.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> KASIA PICKS BRITTANI AND I
TO GO TO ROCKSUGAR
WITH HER AND MISS J.
>> WELCOME TO
ROCKSUGAR PAN ASIAN KITCHEN.
>> WE JUST WALK IN
THIS BEAUTIFUL RESTAURANT.
WE HAVE THIS PRIVATE,
LITTLE V.I.P. AREA.
>> I LOVED IT.
AND I JUST FELT LIKE
I WAS A CELEBRITY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE GET
OUR OWN GOURMET DINNER.
>> KASIA, GREAT WIN
YOU GOT THERE--GO TO DINNER
WITH A BUNCH OF BORING PEOPLE.
MISS J, I'M SURE, IS GONNA HAVE
AMAZING--AN AMAZING TIME.
SO EXCITING.
>> THIS IS A BUSINESS
THAT'S WORD OF MOUTH.
IT REALLY, REALLY IS.
AND PEOPLE LIKE
WORKING WITH NICE PEOPLE.
BUT YOU NEED TO BE STRONG,
YOU NEED TO BE FIRM,
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN BE CRUEL.
SOMEONE CALLING YOU UGLY,
CALLING YOU FAT--LET IT GO.
I'VE BEEN CALLED
EVERY NAME IN THE BOOK.
STICKS AND STONES
MAY BREAK MY BONES,
BUT ALL THOSE UGLY WORDS
MADE ME WEALTHY.
>> (laughs)
IT'S ABSOLUTELY INSPIRING.
I GET--GET TO KNOW MISS J,
AND I ABSOLUTELY LOVED IT.
HE'S SO DOWN TO EARTH,
SO PERSONABLE.
IT WAS, LIKE,
IT WAS A PERFECT EVENING.
AMEN.
>> HEY, GUYS!
>> HOW WAS IT? WHERE'D YOU GO?
>> ROCKSUGAR.
>> WELL, TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> I GOT HOME,
AND HANNAH AND MIKAELA WERE OUT
AND, YOU KNOW, THEY WERE,
LIKE, WONDERING WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT THE DINNER.
MONIQUE WAS STILL
A LITTLE PISSED OFF.
>> IT WAS LIKE...
>> SHARING.
>> THEY JUST PUT ALL THE FOOD
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE THING,
AND THEN YOU ALL PICK AT IT.
>> OH, THAT SOUNDS...
>> LIKE A BUFFET OR SOMETHING?
>> YEAH, KIND OF.
>> OH, I HATE BUFFETS.
>> WHAT KIND OF FOOD?
>> IT WAS REALLY AWKWARD.
THERE WAS A LOT OF TENSION.
MONIQUE DEFINITELY HAS
SOME ENVY, MAYBE.
>> AND YOUR, LIKE,
LITTLE V.I.P. AREA--
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
>> YOU DIDN'T DRINK?
>> IT WAS JUST, YOU KNOW, IT--
>> REALLY LAID-BACK...
>> SUPER CHILL.
>> SOMETIMES, WITH MONIQUE,
I WONDER IF THIS IS
THE RIGHT COMPETITION FOR HER,
BECAUSE SHE'S
KINDA HIGH-MAINTENANCE.
I'M NOT SURPRISED
THAT SHE WAS PISSED
ABOUT CLEANING UP GARBAGE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "OH THE TANGLED WEBS
WE WEAVE!"
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> I WILL DIE IF IT'S A SPIDER.
>> OH, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> WE'RE ALL WORRIED
THAT MAYBE THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME SPIDERS INVOLVED,
BUT I'M JUST GOING TO
TRY TO HAVE
A REALLY GREAT PHOTO SHOOT,
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO,
BUT APPARENTLY,
I HAVEN'T BEEN ACING IT,
SO THAT'S KIND OF
PISSING ME OFF.
>> ♪ SPIDERS! ♪
>> MOMO,
IS THERE ANYTHING BOTHERING YOU?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
I'M JUST, LIKE, IRRITATED.
I JUST WANT TO WIN ONE TIME.
>> ME, TOO.
MONIQUE--SHE'S JUST VERY DOWN,
AND I JUST WISH SHE'D PERK UP.
>> I'M JUST REALLY--
I GET, LIKE,
REALLY ANXIOUS ABOUT IT.
I JUST WANT TO BE, LIKE,
ALONE FOR A LITTLE BIT.
OBVIOUSLY, I'M ON THE (bleep)
VERGE OF AN EMOTIONAL BREAKDOWN
FOR SOME REASON.
I DON'T (bleep) KNOW WHY.
I WANNA TALK TO MY MOM,
AND I WANNA TALK
TO MY BOYFRIEND,
AND I WANNA WIN.
I'M JUST, LIKE,
ON EDGE RIGHT NOW.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE GOT A TYRA MAIL
LAST NIGHT--
"OH THE TANGLED WEBS WE WEAVE!"
>> I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
TANGLED IN SOMETHING.
>> YEAH, I TOTALLY WANT
TO BE TANGLED IN SOMETHING,
AND I HOPE IT'S, LIKE,
JUNGLE VINES.
>> HEY, GUYS. COME ON IN.
COME INSIDE. COME IN.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> WELL, LET ME INTRODUCE YOU
TO THIS MAN.
I GOTTA TELL YOU GUYS,
FIRST OF ALL,
I LOVE SHOOTING WITH JONATHAN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS JONATHAN MANNION,
EVERYBODY.
>> HELLO.
>> HE'S A HIGHLY SOUGHT-AFTER
PHOTOGRAPHER WHO'S SHOT
SOME OF THE TOP CELEBRITIES.
JONATHAN'S WORK IS KNOWN
FOR HAVING A VERY ARTISTIC
AND INTIMATE FEEL TO IT.
WE ARE HERE AT SMASHBOX STUDIOS,
BECAUSE WE NEEDED YOU GUYS
INDOORS,
'CAUSE YOU'RE GONNA BE WEARING
VERY LITTLE.
YOU GUYS ARE ACTUALLY GONNA BE
COVERED IN MUD,
IN GROUPS OF FOUR.
AND ACTUALLY,
LET'S PUT THE BLONDES OVER THERE
AND THE BRUNETTES OVER HERE.
WHO'S GOT IT?
IS IT ALL ABOUT THE BLONDES?
DO BLONDES HAVE MORE FUN?
>> YES.
>> OR IS IT
ALL ABOUT THE BRUNETTES?
>> WHO'S WINNING?
YOU GUYS ARE WINNING?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> OH, MAN.
IT'S A--IT'S A BATTLE.
>> YOU GUYS ARE POSING
LITERALLY AS A GROUP,
SO LAYING OVER ONE ANOTHER.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT
IT BEING A SEXY PHOTO.
IT'S ABOUT AN ARTISTIC--
UM, THIS IS GONNA BE
A BLACK AND WHITE PHOTO.
IN THE MODELING BUSINESS,
A LOT OF SHOOTS,
YOU ARE WITH OTHER MODELS
IN THAT SHOT, SO...
>> BUT YOU GOTTA SHINE
INDIVIDUALLY.
>> LET'S GET YOU GUYS
INTO MAKEUP AND HAIR.
COME ON.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I THINK YOU'RE GOING FIRST
IS THE WORD ON THE STREET.
>> THE BLONDES.
I'M COOL WITH
BEING WITH THE BLONDES.
ALEXANDRIA AGGRAVATES ME
A LITTLE BIT, BUT, LIKE,
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
HAS GOTTEN A BEST PHOTO,
AND NONE OF THE BRUNETTES HAVE,
SO I THINK WE HAVE
A SLIGHT ONE-UP ON THEM.
>> I HOPE THIS MUD
DOESN'T FEEL, LIKE, DRY (bleep).
>> (laughs)
>> I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
THIS WHOLE COMPETITION
TO NOT BE SEXY.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY GONNA BE
A LITTLE HARD,
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE JUST WEARING MUD,
BUT, LIKE, I REALLY LIKE
MY LITTLE GROUP OF BRUNETTES,
AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
GONNA WORK WELL TOGETHER.
>> GIVE YOU A LITTLE--
SOME DIFFERENCE.
>> VERY L.A.
>> OPEN THIS...
>> YEAH.
>> AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> IT'S A LITTLE BIT SEXIER.
>> OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
I AM
THE "FIERCELY REAL SIZE" MODEL.
I'M OKAY WITH IT.
I JUST HAVE TO MAKE SURE
TO FIND MY RIGHT ANGLES,
AND IT'S JUST ABOUT
FINDING THOSE AND, YOU KNOW,
WORKING WITH THE OTHER GIRLS.
>> GET ME DIRTY.
>> SO COLD!
WE'RE ALL COVERED IN MUD,
AND IT'S GONNA BE REALLY RAW,
BUT IT'S HIGH FASHION,
AND I FEEL
REALLY, REALLY POWERFUL
RIGHT NOW, LIKE I JUST
CAME OUT OF THE EARTH,
AND IT'S--IT'S GREAT.
>> REMEMBER,
DON'T START MODELING
SO ON YOUR OWN
THAT YOU FORGET ABOUT
THE OTHER PERSON IN THE SHOT.
DO THE BLONDES RULE?
>> YEAH!
>> ALWAYS.
>> GOOD, GOOD, GOOD. BEAUTIFUL.
I LOVE THAT INTERACTION.
GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS.
GOOD. HOLD THAT.
>> THE BLONDES JUST
KIND OF ALL BLEND TOGETHER.
JUST KIND OF, LIKE, WHO'S WHO?
ALL I SEE IS BLONDE HAIR.
>> MOLLY, THAT'S NICE.
>> I'M NOT THINKING ABOUT
HOW I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I KNOW
THAT IF I JUST DO
WHAT I USUALLY DO, I-I WON'T--
I WON'T BE ANYWHERE
NEAR THE BOTTOM.
>> GORGEOUS, LADIES.
>> LOVE IT, HANNAH.
LOVE THAT POSE AND THE CHIN UP.
>> GOOD. HOLD THAT.
>> ALEXANDRIA,
A LITTLE MORE INTENSITY
FROM YOU.
I KNOW IT'S AWKWARD
'CAUSE YOU'RE
KIND OF FLOATING THERE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
RIGHT NOW, IT'S, LIKE,
MOLLY AND HANNAH ARE
IN THE MIDDLE, LIKE THEY'RE...
>> PERFECT.
>> OWNING THE SHOT.
WHEREAS I FEEL LIKE,
ALEXANDRIA AND KASIA, YOU GUYS
ARE JUST, LIKE, IN A POSE.
YOU'RE NOT TRYING
TO CONNECT IN.
IN THE FIRST SETUP
WITH THE BLONDES, IT WAS
ALL ABOUT HANNAH AND MOLLY.
THEY SOLD IT TO ME.
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> KASIA, IT DOESN'T FEEL
QUITE AS CONNECTED.
I LIKED IT WHEN YOU WERE
A LITTLE UP.
I JUST FEEL LIKE YOU'RE STARTING
TO, EVERY NOW AND THEN,
QUESTION WHAT YOU'RE DOING
ON THE END.
>> THIS KIND OF SHOOT WE DID--
YOU CAN'T MOVE A WHOLE LOT,
AND, LIKE, DIRECTING FOUR GIRLS
WAS KIND OF CHAOTIC.
SO I DIDN'T WANT TO, LIKE,
MAKE A DISTURBANCE,
BUT IT'S, LIKE, NO,
I NEED TO MAKE MYSELF STAND OUT.
>> MUCH BETTER, KASIA.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE WHAT WE GOT.
>> KASIA, ACTUALLY,
PUT YOUR ARM IN FRONT,
BECAUSE I THINK YOU ARE
GONNA NEED SOMETHING TO--YEAH.
>> THAT'S GOOD. THAT'S IT.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
LOVE THIS.
>> WHERE'S THE NOSE PICKER?
>> IS THERE ANY WAY
TO MOVE YOUR ARM ON ME?
>> OH, YOU'RE DROPPING YOUR...
>> HEY, ALEXANDRIA, WHY ARE
YOU REDIRECTING THE SHOT?
>> NO, I'M NOT.
I'M TRYING TO PUT MY HEAD
RIGHT HERE, AND I DON'T WANNA,
LIKE, MAKE HER HAND JUST SEEM...
>> PLEASE LEAVE HER ARM
THE WAY IT IS.
I PUT IT THERE ON PURPOSE.
>> MR. JAY INSTANTLY THOUGHT
THAT I WAS DIRECTING.
IF THAT'S
THE LASTING IMPRESSION
ON MR. JAY'S MIND,
HE'S GONNA SAY IT TO TYRA,
AND... (crying)
IT'S GONNA BE THE END FOR ME.
I JUST DON'T WANT IT TO BE.
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE'S NOT REFORMED AT ALL.
SHE'S STILL THE SAME
DISRESPECTFUL,
CONTROLLING PERSON
THAT SHE WAS A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
>> OKAY, GOOD. THAT'S NICE.
>> CUTE. THERE WE GO.
THE DIRTY BLONDES ARE DONE.
>> AAH!
>> WE'RE GOING TO PERSEVERE,
AND WE'RE GONNA DO IT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> (grunts)
>> TYRA HAS BEEN TELLING ME
THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS
I REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT MY EYES ARE SUPER FIERCE.
THE BOMBSHELL THING IS
NEW TO ME, BUT IT'S SOMETHING
I WANNA EMBRACE,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I INTEND ON DOING.
I HAVE NO CHOICE. (chuckles)
>> GORGEOUS. LADIES, HERE WE GO.
>> CHIN UP JUST A BIT, MONIQUE.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> JACLYN, FIND A BIT
OF AN ANGLE WITH THE FACE.
>> RIGHT.
DON'T GO TOO "LIONESS"...
(lion growls)
>> STALKING HER PREY.
>> WHAT ARE YOU--
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO THINK OF?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M TRYING TO FEEL LIKE
I'M IN THE JUNGLE,
LIKE, IN ATMOSPHERE.
>> YOU'RE GETTING CRUMBS
ON MY FACE. (laughs)
>> CREATIVE IS SPEAKING
FOR ITSELF, SO YOU DON'T REALLY
NEED TO GO ANIMALISTIC, JUNGLEY.
>> THE BRUNETTE THING, LIKE,
LOOKED REALLY BARBARIC IN A WAY.
(men singing
in foreign language)
>> THEY KIND OF LOOKED LIKE
A FAMILY PORTRAIT OF CAVEWOMEN.
(man growls)
>> CHIN UP A BIT, MONIQUE,
THOUGH.
CHIN UP MORE.
SEE WHAT I'M TRYING
TO FIND FOR YOU, MONIQUE,
IS THE STRETCH.
DON'T BRING IT BACK IN.
MONIQUE WOULD FIND A MOMENT
WHERE SHE STRETCHED,
AND IT WAS BREATHTAKING,
BUT THEN YOU'D SEE
THIS LITTLE SWITCH GO OFF--
CLICK--THAT TURNS HER FROM MODEL
TO PRETTY WOMAN.
INTENSITY. FIND YOUR PERK.
>> GOOD.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> GOOD. GREAT, BRITTANI.
LOVING YOUR ENERGY.
YOU'RE JUST BREATHING LIFE
RIGHT INTO THE CENTER OF THIS.
>> BRITTANI--SHE HAS...
BODY POSITIONING DOWN.
JUST HOLD IT FOR ONE SECOND.
SHE HIT A BEAUTIFUL POSE.
I STOPPED AND I TOOK
AN INDIVIDUAL FRAME OF HER.
>> BRITTANI JUST KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S DOING.
>> THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> BRITTANI IS ONE
OF MY BIGGEST COMPETITORS
IN THIS COMPETITION,
AND I KNOW THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
NICE AND CONNECTED.
NICE, STRONG EYES, EVERYONE.
>> MIKAELA, LOSING IT A BIT
IN YOUR EYES.
FIND A WAY
TO MAKE IT PRESENT AGAIN.
MIKAELA WAS HIT-AND-MISS
FOR ME TODAY,
AND WHAT WAS REGISTERING
IN HER EYES--
IT WAS PRETTY LACKLUSTER.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GET THESE GIRLS
UP OUTTA HERE.
>> WELL DONE, LADIES.
>> WRAP ON THE SHOOT!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 7 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING..."
>> "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> HALF, YOU GUYS, HALF.
>> AFTER TOMORROW'S ELIMINATION,
WE'LL BE HALFWAY DONE.
IT'S JUST, LIKE, CONFUSING
AS TO WHO'S GONNA BE CUT NEXT.
NOBODY REALLY DID BAD.
I MEAN, WHO--
>> THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
>> JACLYN A LITTLE BIT.
>> YOU GUYS...
>> SO HOPEFULLY
I STOOD OUT A LOT,
AND HOPEFULLY, I--
I GOT FIRST PHOTO.
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT--
>> SO WHO DID THE BEST
FROM YOU GUYS?
>> (bleep) KINKY.
>> I HOPE SO. I HOPE I DID WELL.
I'M GONNA FREAK THE (bleep) OUT.
I REALLY FEEL LIKE
I WAS IN THE ZONE TODAY,
AND I'M REALLY, REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY HOPING
THAT WHATEVER PICTURE
POPS UP AT PANEL IS
A QUALITY PHOTO.
I NEED TO MOVE UP IN THE RANKS.
I DON'T LIKE FLOATING AROUND.
I DON'T LIKE IT. (groans)
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK I DID GOOD AT--
TOWARD THE END, YOU KNOW,
I THINK I FIGURED IT OUT,
BUT IT WAS A LITTLE BIT--
A ROCKY START.
>> DIDN'T LEX GET
A LOT OF CRITIQUE?
>> WELL,
SHE STARTED DIRECTING AGAIN.
>> SHE DID? ON THE SET?
>> I THINK SHE'S GONNA GO HOME.
ALEXANDRIA TRIED TO DIRECT
EVERYBODY FROM HER END.
SHE THINKS SHE'S REALLY TRYING
TO IMPROVE
AND BE REALLY NICE ON SET,
BUT IT'S REALLY FAKE.
>> (growls)
>> NOBODY WANTS TO WORK
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS
OVERDRAMATIC, COMPLAINS,
TAKES CONTROL,
BOSSES PEOPLE AROUND.
SHE NEEDS TO GO HOME.
>> HEY, MOM AND DAD.
>> I DON'T MIND.
>> SO WHAT YOU CAN DO IS
YOU CAN SAY...
>> HELLO.
DON'T BE LOOKING ME UP AND DOWN.
YOU LOOK AT MY FACE.
>> (laughs)
>> HE WAS, LIKE, "WHAT ARE
THESE FLAT SHOES SHE'S GOT ON?"
>> NO, BABY, NO.
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR SUIT, BABY.
>> HI.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME ABOARD.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
♪♪♪♪♪
HELLO, LADIES.
YOU GUYS KNOW OUR PRIZES--
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THETOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
A COVER OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE"
AND A SPREAD,
AND YOU'LL BE FEATURED
ON vogue.it--THEIR WEB SITE.
MR. NIGEL BARKER--
SEXY, HOT, FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY--ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND SONIA DARA.
SHE WAS THEVERY FIRST MODEL
OF SOUTH ASIAN DESCENT
TO BE FEATURED
IN THE "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
SWIMSUIT ISSUE.
THE BRUNETTES AND THE BLONDES
TEAMED AGAINST EACH OTHER.
>> THE BATTLE
OF THE BRUNETTES AND BLONDES.
>> THE BATTLE OF THE B.B.s.
AND YOU GUYS DID A PHOTO SHOOT
COVERED IN MUD,
INTERTWINED AMONGST EACH OTHER.
AND THE LADIES SHOT
THE LOVELY PHOTOS
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE
AT SMASHBOX STUDIOS.
I WILL CALL UP
THE BRUNETTES FIRST--
JACLYN, MIKAELA,
MONIQUE, AND BRITTANI.
ALL FOUR WERE TOGETHER
IN THE MUD.
>> MM!
>> AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THE PICTURE
IS ALMOST I CAN'T RECOGNIZE
WHO IS WHO, AND I LOVE THAT.
>> YOU'RE WORKING TOGETHER
EXTREMELY WELL.
THERE SEEMS TO BE
SOME REAL GOOD BODY LANGUAGE
GOING ON, AND I'M GONNA START
WITH MONIQUE.
I LOVE JUST, LIKE,
THE HAIR COMING DOWN,
THE GENTLE, SOFT LOOK
IN YOUR EYES.
I THINK THAT HAD YOU EVEN JUST
COLLAPSED EVEN MORE
THEN YOUR BODY AND YOUR FACE
WOULD HAVE GONE TOGETHER.
GOT THE LOOK IN THE FACE.
THE BODY HAS TO FOLLOW.
>> I AGREE WITH NIGEL
THAT YOU COULD'VE, LIKE,
SLOUCHED INTO IT
A LITTLE BIT MORE,
BUT YOUR NECK LOOKS FANTASTIC.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, I THINK
YOU LOOK RELAXED HERE.
I WOULD'VE LIKED TO SEE
YOU PIERCE THROUGH
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE,
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW, I DO FEEL
A COUPLE OF THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE REALLY DOING A CONNECTION,
AND I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE KINDA
SURFING IN THE MIDDLE,
LIKE, NOT BORING,
BUT NOT FIRE EITHER.
>> JACLYN...
WHY ARE YOU LOOKING SO WORRIED?
>> I-I JUST--
I KNOW IN THE BEGINNING
OF MY PHOTO SHOOT,
I WAS GIVING AN ANIMALISTIC FEEL
TO MY EYES,
BUT THEN, UH, MR. JAY TOLD ME
TO JUST BRING IT DOWN A NOTCH,
SO...
>> SO HOW DO YOU THINK
YOUR PICTURE IS?
>> UM, I THINK MY BODY LANGUAGE
COULD'VE BEEN A LITTLE BETTER.
>> I THINK IT'S FABULOUS.
>> I THINK YOU ROCK
IN THIS PICTURE.
THE LOOK IN YOUR FACE,
THE POWER IN YOUR EYES--
IF YOU CAME TO JUDGING
AND YOU STOOD IN FRONT OF ME
WITH THAT KIND OF POWER,
I MAY WELL BOOK YOU.
>> YOUR HANDS LOOKED
A LITTLE BIT HEAVY, FLAT,
BUT YOUR FACE IS STUNNING.
>> WHAT WAS I CHECKING FOR
WHEN I WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR FILM?
YES, AND YOU DID IT, DARLING.
SOMETIMES YOU WOULD GO
LIKE THIS WHERE WE WOULD SEE
ALL THE BOOGERS AND STUFF,
BUT THEN YOU FOUND
A HAPPY MEDIUM,
AND THIS IS THE HAPPY MEDIUM
OF LIFTING UP
AND SHOWING THAT BONE STRUCTURE.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MIKAELA.
>> WEAKEST LINK HERE, FOR ME,
IS MIKAELA.
YOU'VE GOT THIS BONE STRUCTURE,
THESE EYEBROWS,
BUT I-I DON'T FEEL
ANY GREAT DRAMA COMING UP
FROM INSIDE OF YOU.
>> YOU DEFINITELY HAVE
VERY STRONG FEATURES
AND A VERY STRONG
BONE STRUCTURE,
BUT I DON'T SEE IT IN THE EYES.
>> YOU PUT YOUR ENERGY
IN YOUR MOUTH
INSTEAD OF UP HERE,
BUT YOU DID A LOT
OF FANTASTICEYES IN YOUR FILM.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DON'T DO IT ALL THE TIME
IS YOU GET A SHOT
THAT YOU'RE NOT DOING IT,
BECAUSE THE OTHER GIRLS
LOOK GOOD, SO WE HAVE TO FIND
SOMETHING WHERE EVERYBODY
LOOKS GOOD.
THAT'S A LESSON.
AND WE GO TO BRITTANI.
>> BRITTANI, YOU'RE A STANDOUT
IN THIS PICTURE, FOR ME.
>> AND I LOVE THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE THE USUAL
FABULOUS LOUISE BROOKS HAIRDO,
AND YOU DO LOOK AS IF YOU OWN
THIS--THIS PICTURE.
>> YOUR LEFT LEG,
CAMERA RIGHT, IS AMPUTEE'D.
>> (laughs)
>> BUT BECAUSE YOU BORE THROUGH,
THE TECHNICAL
DOESN'T MATTER AS MUCH.
IF YOU CAN CONNECT
WITH YOUR EYES AND YOUR SOUL
AND YOUR SPIRIT,
YOU CAN GO LIKE THIS...
>> YEAH.
>> BUT IF YOU'RE LIKE...
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DID.
THIS IS YOUR PICTURE.
THEY ARE YOUR MAIDENS...
>> YES.
>> AND YOU ARE THE STAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, LADIES.
>> THANK YOU, LADIES.
>> THANK Y'ALL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT, THE BLONDES--
ALEXANDRIA, KASIA,
HANNAH, MOLLY.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD, LADIES.
SO THE BLONDES...
DID YOU OUT-BLONDE
THE BRUNETTES?
(camera shutter clicks)
>> INTERESTING.
THE BLONDES ARE DIFFERENT
THAN THE BRUNETTES.
I W-WISH THERE WAS, IN GENERAL,
A LITTLE BIT MORE BODY LANGUAGE.
BUT THERE'S A LOT
OF GREAT CONCENTRATION.
THERE'S A LOT
OF GREAT EYE CONTACT HERE.
>> IT COULD BE A BILLBOARD
FOR A REMAKE
OF "CHARLIE'S ANGELS:
ALL BLONDES."
>> I KNOW.
I-I-I WANT TO BE BLONDE NOW,
FOR SOME REASON.
FANTASTIC.
>> HANNAH, I THINK THIS IS
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL SHOT OF YOU.
>> THERE'S THOUGHT
IN YOUR PHOTO.
I FEEL,
BEHIND YOUR BEAUTIFUL FACE,
YOU ARE THINKING,
THERE IS EMOTIONAL RANGE.
>> I AGREE.
YOU KIND OF HAVE THIS, LIKE,
DOE-LIKE FACE,
SO YOU'RE VERY CALM,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU'RE DELIVERING THE INTENSITY.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK STUNNING,
BUT I DO WISH THAT YOU WOULD'VE
DONE A LITTLE BIT MORE, LIKE,
PULLING IN, RELAXING,
BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
KIND OF FEELING EACH OTHER,
AND I FEEL A LITTLE SENSE
OF CLASS PORTRAIT-Y.
MOLLY.
>> GORGEOUS. SUPER GORGEOUS.
THANK GOD
YOU GOT RID OF THE WEAVE.
>> I THINK THAT YOU LOOK
EXTRAORDINARY AS WELL.
YOU HAVE A SLIGHTLY WEAK EYE.
YOUR LEFT EYE IS
LOOKING A LITTLE SMALL.
YOU'VE GOTTA BE CAREFUL OF THAT
IN A PICTURE, OKAY?
JUST TRY AND FIND THE LIGHT
IN BOTH EYES.
>> KASIA.
>> KASIA, LIKE, MY EYES
DEFINITELY WENT TO YOU FIRST.
I THINK YOUR INTERACTIONS
WITH THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE PERFECT.
FANTASTIC JOB.
>> KASIA, YOUR FILM--
I-I LOVED IT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF SHOTS
WHERE YOU WERE ON THE END,
AND YOU WERE LEANING
AND WORKING,
AND IT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
I FIND IT A LITTLE BIT POSE-Y,
THIS, LIKE, "I'M TRYING
TO GET IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
I DON'T WANT TO BE LEFT OUT."
>> ALEXANDRIA,
YOU FELL OFF THIS WEEK.
YOU WERE LYING DOWN
IN THE FRONT.
YOU FACE WAS GONE.
THE LIGHT WASN'T GOOD,
AND YOU JUST
KINDA JUST STAYED THERE
AS OPPOSED TO JUST TWEAKING IT
AND TURNING IT.
BUT WITH THIS PHOTO,
I LOVE YOUR BACK HUNCHED.
I LOVE YOU PUSHING IN.
I LOVE EVERYTHING ABOUT IT.
IT'S JUST--
IT WAS NOT CONSISTENT.
THANK YOU, LADIES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND CONGRATULATIONS, KASIA,
FOR A CHALLENGE WIN. YOU WON!
>> YES.
>> GREAT!
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS, LADIES.
NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH BRUNETTE
OR WHICH BLONDE
IS ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IT IS TIME FOR US
TO DELIBERATE.
THE BLONDES AND THE BRUNETTES.
>> BRUNETTES AND BLONDES.
(speaks indistinctly)
>> LET'S START
WITH THE BRUNETTES--
BRITTANI, JACLYN, MIKAELA,
AND MONIQUE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I LOVE
ABOUT THE BRUNETTES IS
THAT IT IS A LITTLE AWKWARD,
IT IS A LITTLE FLIP-FLOPPED.
BUT I LOOK AT IT--
THERE'S ALSO A PASSION.
>> THIS IS DEFINITELY
MORE EDITORIAL.
THIS WOULD BE
IN A HIGH FASHION MAGAZINE,
AND THE BLONDES...
>> AND THE BLONDES
WOULD BE A BILLBOARD...
>> YES, I-I AGREE AND THIS--
>> ON THE ROAD, 405.
>> YES. (laughs)
>> JACLYN.
>> JACLYN, I THINK,
LOOKS EXTRAORDINARY.
I THINK THE BODY LANGUAGE
DEFINITELY NEEDS SOME WORK.
THE FACE, THOUGH, HAS GOT POWER.
IT'S INTERESTING WITH HER,
ISN'T IT, THAT SHE DOES LOOK
DO DIFFERENT IN PERSON
FROM THE WAY SHE PHOTOGRAPHS?
>> (high-pitched voice) SHE
LOOKS LIKE THIS IN PERSON. OOH!
>> (high-pitched voice) OOH!
I'M SO EXCITED TO BE HERE!
>> (normal voice) YEAH.
>> WHOO-HOO-HOO!
>> BUT SHE TURNS IT ON.
I MEAN, THE PHOTOGRAPHS OF HER
ARE QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
>> MONIQUE.
>> (normal voice) MONIQUE.
HER PERSONALITY--
IT DOESN'T MATTER, BECAUSE WHEN
SHE STANDS BEFORE YOU,
YOU ALMOST CAN'T READ HER,
BUT SHE MANAGES TO PULL IT OFF
IN THE PHOTOGRAPHS.
BUT IS THAT GOOD OR IS THAT BAD?
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
WITH MONIQUE.
SHE'S KINDA SAILING
IN THE MIDDLE.
>> SAILING ALONG THE MIDDLE.
>> NEVER THE WORST.
>> YEAH.
>> NEVER THE BEST. SHE JUST--
>> BUT SHE'S STILL HOLDING ON.
LIKE SHE COULD WORK, BUT, MM...
>> MM.
>> THERE'S NO TENSION.
IF YOU TOOK HER OUT
OF THIS PICTURE,
THE PICTURE'S JUST AS STRONG.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> MIKAELA.
>> I FEEL LIKE,
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS,
SHE'S THE LEAST EDITORIAL.
SHE HAS THE BONE STRUCTURE
FOR IT, BUT, LIKE,
THE WAY SHE COMES ACROSS
ISN'T REALLY GIVING
THAT SENSE OF PERSONALITY
AND THAT DRIVE.
>> IT'S NOT ONLY
A PHYSICAL BEAUTY.
YOU HAVE TO EVOKE SOMETHING
FROM WITHIN THE DEPTHS
OF WHO YOU ARE, AND I DON'T
GET THAT WITH MIKAELA.
>> BRITTANI.
>> BRITTANI HERE IS
THE STAR OF THE PHOTO.
>> SHE'S BRINGING IT.
>> AND I LOVE THAT SORT OF, UH,
MEAN, DEFIANT POUT.
IT'S VERY INTRIGUING.
>> I THINK, FOR ME, BRITTANI IS
THE MOST MODERN ONE
OF THE BUNCH.
I LOOK AT HER--
SHE'S CONTEMPORARY.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT HER
THAT-THAT-THAT'S ELECTRIC.
>> ARE YOU READY
FOR THE BLONDES?
>> THE BLONDES.
>> HANNAH.
>> SHE'S ONE OF THOSE MODELS
THAT IS
VERY PHYSICALLY ATTRACTIVE
IN PERSON
AND PHOTOGRAPHS
PRETTY MUCH AS YOU SEE HER.
SHE'S NOT THE CHAMELEON.
>> YEAH.
>> AND--AND, YOU KNOW, THAT
WORKS FOR COMMERCIAL MODELING.
>> I THINK SHE'S BEAUTIFUL
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
BUT IT JUST DOESN'T GIVE ME
THE IMPACT OF BEAUTY
THAT I NEED.
>> SO SHE'S NOT LAYING, LIKE,
TILTING THAT HEAD AND...
>> MNH-MNH. SHE'S--NO, NO, NO.
>> KASIA.
>> YOU SEE HER FIRST
IN THE PHOTO, AND SHE IS
ALSO A VERY SWEET GIRL
FROM WHAT I COULD TELL.
>> FEEL HER ENERGY.
>> YEAH, YOU FEEL HER ENERGY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SHE'D BE SOMEBODY WHO I KNOW
A LOT OF CLIENTS WOULD LIKE.
>> KASIA IS THE HIGHLIGHT
OF THIS.
>> THESE ARE HER BACKUP SINGERS
IN THE BACK OF HER.
>> YES, THESE ARE
HER BACKUP SINGERS.
>> MOLLY.
>> THIS IS A GREAT SHOT
OF MOLLY. MOLLY IS BACK.
THE BODY LANGUAGE IS GOOD.
THE LEGS ARE GOOD.
>> THERE'S A CONFIDENCE THERE.
>> TOTALLY.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> ALEXANDRIA--IT FEELS LIKE
SHE'S TRYING TO GET IN
ON THE SHOT.
"LET ME IN. LET ME IN."
>> HER OUTFIT LOOKED
A LITTLE STRANGE TO ME, TOO.
>> WHAT WAS THAT TASSEL
AND THAT BONNET?
IT WAS OVER-DRECK, OUT.
>> BEYOND DRECKITUDE.
>> OVER.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
>> YES.
>> IS IT A BLONDE...
>> OR A BRUNETTE?
>> FOUR BLONDES
AND FOUR BRUNETTES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SEVEN OF YOU
THAT ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL
IS AMONGST THE GROUP
THAT THE JUDGES THINK IS
THE STRONGEST GROUP SHOT.
>> BRITTANI.
FIRST TIME
THAT YOU'RE CALLED FIRST.
BEST PHOTO.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING... (growls)
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (laughs) THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL
IS RUNNER-UP...
A BLONDE--KASIA.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> CONGRATULATIONS, KASIA.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> MOLLY.
JACLYN.
>> (whispers) EXCUSE ME.
>> THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL
IS...
>> HANNAH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
(normal voice) THE NEXT NAME
I'M GONNA CALL...
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> ANDRÉ HAS SOMETHING
TO TELL YOU ABOUT THIS OUTFIT.
>> THE TASSEL
AND THE BONNET TOGETHER
DOES NOTWORK.
THE DRECKITUDE OF IT ALL!
>> AND THE BONNET.
>> OH.
>> NO PICTURE
UNTIL THE BONNET IS GONE.
THERE SHE IS. THERE SHE IS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL MIKAELA AND MONIQUE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> SO IT HAD TO COME DOWN
TO TWO BRUNETTES.
THE BRUNETTES PREVAILED
IN THE GROUP SHOT
BECAUSE THE JUDGES FELT
THAT YOU GUYS' PICTURE WAS
MORE HIGH FASHION,
AND THAT THE BLONDES' PICTURE
WAS MORE
OF A COMMERCIAL BILLBOARD,
NOT A HIGH FASHION BILLBOARD.
BUT WE BREAK THE PICTURES DOWN
INDIVIDUALLY,
AND THE JUDGES FEEL THAT YOU TWO
ARE THE WEAKEST.
MIKAELA, SAME NOTE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN--
DEAD EYES.
YOU DON'T HOLD ON
TO WHAT I CALL
THE HANDLEBARS OF FIERCENESS.
YOU HOLD ON, YOU LET GO,
AND IT COMES BACK TO BITE YOU
IN A GROUP SHOT.
AND THEN WE HAVE MONIQUE.
THE JUDGES SEE,
FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
IS SOMEBODY THAT'S NOT THE BEST
AND SOMEBODY
THAT'S NOT THE WORST,
SOMEBODY WHOSE PERSONALITY
THEY KINDA FEEL
BUT NOT REALLY.
THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW MONIQUE,
SOMEBODY THAT SAILS
IN THE MIDDLE.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
WE ENJOY THE PEAKS, MIKAELA,
AND WE WANT TO SEE MORE OF THEM.
>> SO YOU HAVE TO HOLD ON
TO THAT.
>> I'M TRYING.
>> AND DON'T HOLD ON
TO WHERE YOU START SHAKING,
AND, LIKE OOH!
LET IT GO. COME BACK.
>> I KNOW. RIGHT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
I LOVED EVERY MINUTE
OF YOU BEING IN THIS COMPETITION
BECAUSE OF THIS.
REMINDS ME OF ME
BACK IN THE DAY.
I REPRESENTED THAT.
YOU HAVE THAT BODY
AND YOU HAVE
A STUNNING, STUNNING FACE,
AND IT'S UP TO YOU
TO NOT SAIL IN THE MIDDLE,
THOUGH.
YOU HAVE TO STAND OUT.
OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> (crying)
I'M SORRY. (speaks indistinctly)
>> (crying) I'M JUST, LIKE,
REALLY SHOCKED RIGHT NOW,
LIKE, I DIDN'T REALLY
SEE THAT COMING.
I'VE BEEN FEELING MYSELF
SKATING ALONG IN THE MIDDLE,
AND IT'S BEEN
REALLY PISSING ME OFF,
LIKE, I'VE BEEN REALLY TRYING
TO--TO FULLY GO AFTER IT,
BUT I-I DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S SOMETHING INSIDE OF ME
JUST, LIKE, HOLDING BACK
A LITTLE BIT.
I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THAT WAS,
BUT, LIKE, I DIDN'T WANT
TO GO HOME YET.
(sniffles)
SO IT--IT REALLY SUCKS.
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.